Bon appetit.
the last time I posted this recipe, you guys bore it up.
you guys love this recipe so much
that so many of you guys remade it.
so today, I'm gonna share this recipe again.
this is garlic, green beans, melting some butter.
once this is halfway melted, we're gonna add some salt,
garlic powder, and red pepper flakes.
if you want it to burn your booty hole,
but not really burn your booty hole,
could you already know how it is over here on this page?
mix this until it's all melted.
no. my toddlers tripping.
now we're gonna add our green beans.
we're going to cook this until there's a bright green.
we're going to eat this then.
I took and die to this long.
should I cut that up? and they got teeth.
once there's a nice bright green,
we're going to add our garlic.
at this point, you can turn off your heat
and let the residual heat do the rest.